je voudrais vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire de haut animés ou à nîmes est
un prénom sénoufo qui signifie
littéralement à l'ombre de quelqu'un
c'est un prénom que l'on donne à un
enfant qu'on aimerait placé sous la
protection de dieu
lawani mais dont je vous parle ce soir
est une enfant qui est né qui a grandi
ici en côte d'ivoire elle était curieuse
de tout elle était espiègle et surtout
elle donnait l'impression de vivre dans
son monde parce qu'elle avait une façon
particulière de faire les choses une
fois son père est rentré du travail et
il était mécontent parce qu'ils étaient
20 ans passés elle était encore assise
devant la télé il a donc dit à sa maman
qu'il allait lui même la faire coucher
quelques minutes après la mer étonné
voit sortir de la chambre la petite voix
ni mais alors qu'elle s'attendait à voir
son mari est quant à lui a posé
d'internât question de ça va mais animés
vrai papa elle lui a répondu à un moment
je pense qu'il était plus fatigué que
moi et papa eto'o c'est moi qui les fais
domiens quand son petit frère aîné
l'unique garçon de la fratrie
son père était heureux et quand il est
allé à la maternité il a dit au petit
garçon mon fils je suis content que tu
sois là je suis content c'est vrai mais
j'ai quelque chose à te dire et un autre
garçon qui t'attend à la maison mais là
les portent des jupes et depuis il a
toujours appelé son premier garçon le
plus beau cadeau que ses parents lui ont
fait a toujours été de l'aimer tel
qu'elle était de l'accepter au lieu de
vouloir la changer et de l'accompagner
ce qui lui a permis très tôt de savoir
ce qu'elle voulait être
et surtout ce qu'elle ne voulait pas
mon nom est sarah ou animés coulibaly et
je suis la petite oignies mais je suis
très ému d'être là ce soir et je suis
très émue également de vous montrer
cette photo de moi parce que de cette
enfance dont je parle avec beaucoup
d'humour et de nostalgie
il ne me reste que cette image
malheureusement comme beaucoup d'entre
vous ma famille a été victime de la
crise postélectorale en très peu de
temps nous avons tout perdu
je n'ai plus d'image de moi enfant et
cette image est la seule image qui me
reste ce que je garde dans le coeur ce
sont ces choses immatérielles qui me qui
me suivent quel que soit l'endroit où je
suis et je comprends maintenant à manger
ou à mon âge adulte que le but plus beau
cadeau que vous pouvez faire à vos
enfants ce sont ces moments là qui n'ont
pas de prix et surtout cette amo comme
jocelyne le disait roselyne le disait
pardon je suis très contente de me
retrouver ce soir à grand bassam
parce que très peu de personnes le
savent mais monsieur le maire j'avais su
vécu ici pendant deux ans c'est ici à
grand bassam que j'ai obtenu mon
baccalauréat et c'est donc ici à grand
bassam que j'ai découvert le monde
essaie grand bassam qui m'a ouvert les
portes du monde
à 16 ans et demi le bac en poche je
décide de m'installer à bruxelles
je voulais y faire des études
d'architecturé larchitecture parce que
on avait très tôt décelé en moi un
talent créatif et c'était pour moi un
métier qu'elle me permet de m'exprimer
là bas à bruxelles j'ai rencontré mon
ami primes prime et chinoise est comme
moi elle avait quitté son pays pour
s'installer dans le pays du manneken pis
nous sommes prêtes au devenus amis on
était inséparable et au bout de quelques
temps mon amie m'a dit qu'elle s'était
rapproché de moi parce qu'elle était
fasciné par la couleur de ma peau et
parlait de presse que je portais j'avoue
que moi aussi je vais passer du temps
avec elle parce qu'on puisse à cuisiner
bien et puis c'est pour le canada qui
est surtout j'en apprenais beaucoup plus
de sa culture basque finalement on est
toujours mieux raconter sous poteau par
soi même mais je me suis quand même
poser une question nous avions 16 ans et
demi nous sortirons nous étions de
jeunes adolescents je n'arrivais pas à
comprendre que mon ami me disent
qu'elles n'avaient jamais vu quelqu'un
comme moi c'est vrai je peux comprendre
que la chine soit loin de mon korhogo
natale mais quand même moi enfant
j'avais déjà reçu des jouets qui
ressemblait à mon ami trine j'avais déjà
reçu des poupées qui ressemble même à
mon amie vanessa l'ukrainienne je ne
comprends donc pas qu'une personne comme
moi lui semble totalement étrangère je
me suis donc posé la question de savoir
si j'étais représenté dans mon identité
à cette étape cruciale de la
construction d'une personne parce que
oui finalement c'est pendant l'enfance
qu'on devient un être social
sociable c'est pendant l'enfance qu'on
apprend à accepter l'autre et qu'on
apprend à savoir un peu plus sur lui
donc si à ce moment là moi je suis
absente en tant que personne mais
finalement comment est ce que je vais
pouvoir me faire accepter plus tard
comment est-ce que je ne serai pas
victime des clichés de la société au
moment je pense que je peux m'exprimer
et puis finalement j'ai quitté la
belgique parce que je me suis rendu
compte que l'architecturé ce n'était pas
pour moi j'étais certes créative mais je
ne voulais pas rester dans un bureau je
me suis donc installé en france
et là bas j'ai commencé dans le fond de
ma chambre d'étudiant à fabriquer des
accessoires et les chaussures je le
faisais pour des amis pour des amis
d'amis bénévolement et finalement cette
petite activité a commencé à être
créative et grâce à la magie des réseaux
sociaux
j'avais de plus en plus de commandes
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
je tenais là une première idée
d'entreprise et j'ai donc décidé de me
professionnaliser
je suis retourné à l'université de ma
ville et je me suis inscrite je me suis
inscrite pour faire un master en
création d'entreprise le sésame pour
faire cette formation était d'avoir un
projet je suis donc allé avec mon idée
elle était toute simple je pensais que
nous étions je trouvais que nous étions
des femmes pyatt parisienne mme avec des
origines
donc je vous l'affirmé mes origines ont
pas autant sur moi des accessoires qui
me permettait d'affirmer mon identité
tout en étant adaptés à ma vie et donc
je voulais créer une marque de
chaussures ethnique d'inspiration
africaine
le premier jour de classe nous nous
sommes retrouvés autour du professeur
nous devient de papeete être accompagne
quinzaine de personnes massées sion et
chacun devait parler de son projet je
devais être je pense la douzième
personne sur le tour de table et là j'ai
entendu monsieur moi je voudrais faire
des t-shirts blancs
monsieur moi je voudrais faire un
logiciel déjà vu monsieur monsieur est
là mon tour arrivé et j'ai commencé a
littéralement foncé dans ma chaise mais
comment est ce que je leur ai expliqué
ce que je voulais faire comme angèle a
expliqué ce que c'est que le pagne kita
le bogolans ou même le coup bas du
kassaï il ne connaissait pas mon projet
me paraissait trop peu commun et comme
mon tour est arrivé je me suis exprimée
et je les dis monsieur je veux créer une
ligne de chaussures et là j'ai reçu
l'une des plus belles leçons de ma vie
il m'a écouté pendant quelque temps et
il a dit tu sais ça rame
j'aime bien ton projet parce que
finalement nous on a notre place ce
qu'on attend c'est qu'on nous montre
qu'on nous demande des choses qu'on n'a
pas déjà vus et donc j'aime bien parce
que ce que tu me racontes sait des
choses que je ne sais pas et je trouve
un projet original le mot était lâché
originalité et j'ai compris là qu'en
fait aujourd'hui il fallait faire la
différence pour pouvoir finalement se
trouver une place parce que nous sommes
dans un monde où quasiment tout a été
fait en 2014
j'ai vécu une grèce dieu m'a donné la
graisse de l'enfantement j'attendais mon
premier enfant
et là j'ai commencé à chercher dans les
magasins des jouets qui me ressemblaient
vous ressembler à ma fille je n'en ai
pas trouvé
je vais chercher ici à l'extérieur je ne
les ai pas trouvés et je me suis souvenu
de mon ami trine et de tout ce que
j'avais vécu moi est ce que j'avais
ressenti plus tôt et j'ai compris que
finalement le problème n'était pas
résolu
il n'existait pas ou quasiment pas de
jouer qui me ressemblait dans les rayons
alors entrepreneur que je suis femme
maman et citoyenne du monde j'ai décidé
de m'engager et en même temps que ma
fille naissait aînés naïma dolls les
jouets les poupées de naïma
en créant naïma j'ai simplement voulu
mettre à la disposition des enfants du
monde
ce que j'aurais voulu retrouver pour mes
propres enfants parce que je pense qu'il
est important que nos enfants puissent
grandir avec des personnages auxquels
ils peuvent s'identifier
mon entreprise est 100% féminine nous
sommes toutes des mamans tout c'est pour
cela que vous verrez que dans tous les
jouets qu'on conçoit il y a beaucoup
d'amour parce que nous n'avons que ça a
donné à ses enfants
certaines personnes décident de planter
des arbres moi j'ai décidé de planter
des âmes est la fête la terre la plus
fertile que j'ai trouvé vos plantes et
ses arbres ses âmes pardon c'est le
coeur de nos enfants dans les âmes que
je voudrais planté vous trouverez nos
valeurs notre identité notre richesse
vous trouverez notre africanité et de
sésame né sont des fruits tels que la
confiance en soi
l'intégrité l'abnégation le courage et
surtout les valeurs
mon souhait de planter ces âmes saison
ces femmes dans le coeur de nos enfants
c'est vrai mais pas uniquement
je voudrais les plantes et également
dans le coeur des enfants d'ailleurs
pour bâtir afin de bâtir pour nos
enfants dépend de dignité qui met enfin
à des fléaux tels que l'immigration
clandestine
parce que finalement six enfants ils
apprennent à se connaître ils pourront
se parler de choeur à coeur et j'espère
qu'à 18 ans quant à imarat à l'étranger
et qu'elle dira à son ami je viens de la
côte d'ivoire son ami lui dira je
connais ton pays parce que j'ai vu une
poupée qui te ressembler et elles sont
belles les femmes de chez toi
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais vous poser une question est
ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler de
la transition démographique
c'est très simple vous connaissez c'est
très bien c'est simplement un moment où
on se rende compte que le taux de
mortalité baisse et le taux de natalité
heures demande en france est tout simple
on va devenir plus nombreux dans pas
longtemps d'accord donc là en naissant
en 2050 on sera deux sens c'est très
simple aujourd'hui à 1 milliard
d'africains sur cette terre et en
éduquant 2050 où seront 2 milliards 400
millions
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi je
ressens en ce moment une dynamique
il ya des pépites qui sortent de notre
continent il ya des personnes qui font
des choses extraordinaires dans tous les
domaines que ce soit dans le domaine de
l'art de la musique je vous parle de
personnes comme angélique kidjo
chimamanda ngozi toutes ces personnels
même monsieur le député monsieur le
préfet pardon il a toutes ces personnes
là qui affirme leur authenticité et je
pense qu'elles ont un seul point commun
elles savent d'où ils viennent
elles n'ont pas peur de le revendiquer
ce que je voudrais vous dire ce soir
c'est très simple
finalement comme mon professeur me l'a
dit à quelques années le monde attend de
nous qu'on lui dise la seule chose qui
ne s'est pas de nous parce que
finalement l'afrique ce n'est pas que le
sida
ce n'est pas que la guerre ou du moins
ce n'est plus ça et très bientôt ça ne
sera plus du tout ça il faut donc que
nous commencions dès maintenant à
préparer cette nouvelle génération en
leur donnant les bonnes armes pour faire
d'eux de bons ambassadeurs
je ne vous dis pas que ça sera facile je
ne pense pas que toutes ces personnes là
vous disent qu'ils aient vécu une vie
facile
- en tant qu'entrepreneur je peux vous
dire que ce n'est pas facile
ah non ce n'est pas facile entreprendre
ça fait peur entreprendre sa demande
d'avoir un mental de sportifs parce que
nous sommes tout le temps
confrontés à nos limites j'ai souvent eu
peur très souvent j'ai eu peur quand en
2018 à mon bureau nous avons été
victimes des inondations etc à quelques
mois de la fête de noël nous avons perdu
plus de 80% de notre stock j'ai eu peur
mais les femmes qui ma compagne et moi
même nous sommes battus nous avons
continué et cette année là nous étions
malgré tout sous les sapins
c'est ce qui me permet de vous dire ce
soir que naïma dolls et après toutes ces
années d'expérience la première marque
de jouets africaine qui a pour ambition
de très bientôt aller titiller les
grandes marques peau qu'à la fin nos
enfants ne trouvent pas seulement dans
nos rayons des jouets qui leur
ressemblent mais qu'ils puissent des
trouvaient également à new york où
beaucoup plus loin tous ces enfants
l'âme appelle affectueusement tata
sahara tout le monde m'appelle tata sa
rage et beaucoup d'enfants de jeumont a
donné deux mais j'ai beaucoup d'enfants
de choeur
c'est pour cela que 2020 également lé
début pour moi de l'activité de notre
fondation
nous avons déjà commencé bénévolement à
donner à notre communauté et surtout à
partager ce message finalement qui a
important pour que nous puissions
comprendre que le au delà du jeu au delà
du jeu un enfant se construit et il est
important dès le bas âge d'avoir des
bons repères nous allons donc continuer
à aller voir toutes les couches de la
société pour que tous les enfants
puissent avoir chez eux une poupée un
jouet naïma et qui puisse se regarder en
se disant je suis beau je suis belle je
peux aller plus loin
mesdames et messieurs je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure de transition
démographique
je vous ai parlé de oignies mai mais ce
que je n'oublie pas de vous dire c'est
que le thème de ce thé dic c'est la
préhistoire
je voudrais parler de 2050 je vais vous
parler de 2100 2050
c'est donc 30 ans puisque nous sommes en
2020 est ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que comme vous moi j'ai des aïeux j'ai
des ancêtres mais ce que vous ne savez
pas où peut-être que vous n'avez pas
mesuré c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
à la préhistoire de cette histoire vous
êtes les ancêtres de ces enfants dont je
vous parle de ses enfants qui doivent
porter loin le flambeau de l'afrique et
changer l'image qu'on peut avoir de nous
c'est pour cela que dès aujourd'hui
l'important que vous puissiez prendre
vos responsabilités et que vous fassiez
attention à la manière dont vous éduquer
vos enfants parce que l'amour que vous
allez leur donner eux le donnera à leur
tour à leurs enfants
et finalement je pense que plus tard en
2100 en 2050 on vous dira que l'afrique
a changé de visage
vous savez ma mère ya un proverbe qui
dit souvent elle dit que quelle que soit
la robustesse du corps qu'on a si on
décide d'utiliser de l'argile pour s'en
faire des mollets à la moindre érosion
tout s'écroule ce que je veux vous dire
par là c'est que c'est bien de faire
voyager vos enfants c'est bien de les
envoyer dans les plus belles et les plus
grandes universités du monde
mais n'oubliez pas l'ancrage n'oubliez
pas de leur dire d'où ils viennent et
qu'ils sont parce que finalement tous
ces beaux cadeaux c'est beau c'est bien
mais finalement comme moi je garde à
coeur c'est moment inoubliable
inoubliable avec mes parents je peux
vous dire que le plus beau cadeau que
vous ferez à vos enfants c'est de leur
donner des racines et des ailes je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]